we got a real quick catch up on
barbie like people are like so excited
they can't even handle it they don't
even know what to do with themselves
about this movie what can we expect when
this finally hits theaters we get to see
a little piece of it
i would say expect the
unexpected i don't think you know what's
coming i no i don't
i don't know no one does
yeah you're not supposed to i mean this
looks like a really cute project
talking about working with that young
man i mean i met him earlier he was like
i met mysterio he was very excited he's
the cutest kid i've ever met ever
um i've actually never met him till
today
um i've heard his voice and recorded to
his voice um
but he's so brilliant and perfect as
elio yeah talk to me what are we gonna
see when we're able to see more of this
film and the full film yeah well i mean
it's a pixar movie so that right there
tells you it's gonna be great um adrian
molina who co-directed coco wrote and
directed it and and it's so full of
heart and humor and fun
you know we get to be in outer space
which is awesome who doesn't want to be
in outer space and then it's full of so
much heart and and just a beautiful
message about
self-acceptance and a beautiful message
for parents about accepting
your kid
for everything they are even the things
that you don't really quite understand
i mean i can say i've got a
four-year-old and a 15 month old and
it's like that is uh that's a real thing
right like this is what you this is who
you are and and i that's what i have to
get used to right i have a four-year-old
and a two-year-old and yeah the
the beautiful message
that is becoming more mainstream for
parents which is like it's not your job
to shape them it's your job
to to make space for them to be all of
the wonderful things that they already
are and i have a four-year-old and a
two-year-old so similar ages
in the thick of it
okay you know you're gonna make sure i'm
just gonna do it like eyes eyes how are
you doing you all right listen
i'm on a work trip
eight hours of sleep last night i feel
great
don't tell my husband